[Música]
a
desde el comienzo de la cuarta onda los
territorios de ultramar para solamente
las antillas se han convertido en la
prioridad de franza en la gestión de la
pandemia para frenar la propagación del
virus se han aplicado medidas
restrictivas y de privatización de
libertad y de libertades en esos
territorios que representan el 4 por
ciento por ciento de la población
francesa en guadalupe y martinica donde
1 de cada 5 habitantes están
contaminados se han puesto en marcha
esta semana un respirito confinamiento
en la polinesia y la buena francesa
también se aplicará un toque de queda y
como los hospitales están saturados y se
enfrentan a la falta de personal esta
semana 264 enfermeras y 60 bomberos
salieron del hexágono para ayudar al
gobierno francés recuerda que los
refuerzos hospitalarios y las
rescisiones son soluciones a soluciones
a corto plazo insistieron en la
vacunación masiva en algunos territorios
de ultramar sólo el 20 por ciento de la
población ha recibido la primera dosis
frente al 77% en el hexágono
[Música]
la estrategia del gobierno británico es
vacunar a las casi 250.000 personas que
viven en sus 14 territorios ultramar
para tratar de frenar así las
infecciones por kobe 19 esta vacunación
avanza casi tan rápidamente como en el
propio reino unido e incluso en algunas
zonas ya se concluyó este proceso de
inmunización venciendo todo tipo de
obstáculos logísticos y de acceso dado
que una parte importante de esos
territorios ultramar están ubicados en
los puntos más remotos del planeta en el
caso de las islas cayman las más grandes
con la población de aproximadamente 65
mil personas al menos un 71% de la
población ha recibido una dosis de la
vacuna pero cada día aumentan los casos
de quienes no quieren recibirla por eso
ese porcentaje está congelado según la
prensa local en el caso de gibraltar se
convirtió en marzo de este año en el
primer país en inmunizar completamente a
su población pero los casos de
infecciones están aumentando en las
últimas semanas en el caso de las islas
malvinas también se ha inmunizado gran
parte de su población
puerto rico- forma parte de este país
pero es uno de los estados libres con
estatus de autogestión por eso en la
mayoría de los temas se autogestión a sí
mismos y con esta pandemia no ha sido
menos a pesar de eso le echan en cara al
gobierno central que no le ha apoyado lo
suficiente las últimas ayudas que han
recibido han sido cuatro mil millones de
dólares para la educación en medio de
esta pandemia aún así el gobierno de
puerto rico sigue diciendo que no es
suficiente para hacer frente a todo lo
que se le viene encima en puerto rico
hay 33 millones de habitantes y el 76
por ciento de la población ya ha
recibido al menos una vacuna ahora
luchan como en otras partes de eeuu para
que ese proceso de vacunación no se
quede estancado por eso el gobernador
anunció hace pocos días que todos los
trabajadores públicos estarán obligados
a vacunarse antes de que termine el mes
y además esta semana ha anunciado
también que el próximo 23 de agosto a
partir del próximo 23 de agosto será
obligatorio que todas aquellas personas
que trabajan ofreciendo comida o bebida
estén vacunadas y los clientes deberán
estar vacunados también o presentar una
prueba de kobe negativa para poder
acceder a los locales
[Música]